good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight we're coming up on the
two-year anniversary of the bite
Administration if you can even believe
it seems like a day
Pete put a judge has been there almost
the whole time he was sworn in in early
February of 2021 and when he was he had
high hopes we looked at the tape today
though we had no previous experience
with Transportation or for that matter
was secretarial work Buddha judge held
up his right hand and swore an oath to
Kamala Harris to be the best darn
Secretary of Transportation he could be
and he seemed to mean it but not for
long sadly history soon intervened just
weeks into the job Buddha judge
discovered that some of the roads he was
supposed to be overseeing the roads he
was now Secretary of were in fact racist
and not just low-grade got drunk and
wrote insensitive Facebook posts 10
years ago racist not that kind of racist
no these were hardcore David Duke level
nasty old segregationist roads these
were roads that refused to respond to
reason and clearly had no intention of
changing and joining the 21st century
some of these roads literally had white
stripes painted on them white stripes
Jim Crow stuff
Buddha judge seemed shocked by the whole
thing they don't have roads like that
back in South Bend Indiana
so for Pete butter judge it was a pivot
point it was one of those moments of
profound disillusionment so common to
high-minded Young newcomers to
Washington where everything changes in
an instant all your preconceptions
washed away here he'd sworn an oath to
take care of the roads but learned the
hard way that some roads are Beyond
repair they are too racist to fix
so Pete put a judge embarked on another
path he became one of America's foremost
religious leaders as an Episcopalian it
was not an easy transition traditionally
members of the clergy believe in God but
Buddha judge had a characteristically
clever solution an approach he had
learned during his years as a McKinsey
consultant
in place of the concept of an omnipotent
loving God who brings Justice to the
world Buddha judge simply substituted
the word climate thanks be to climate
our climate Who Art in Heaven that kind
of thing and it sounded pretty good
here's one of his sermons you talk very
openly about being a person of faith and
I I want to understand
how you connect that to this issue of
climate change and our custodianship of
the earth and our moral responsibilities
climate is a moral issue and this is
about stewardship it is about Justice
there's a moment here where we should
invite those who are motivated by
religious moral considerations to know
that those are some of the things that
are at stake in what we're doing to this
to this planet
so this was really a milestone in modern
Christian theology climate declared
father Buddha judge is a moral issue not
a meteorological matter not even a
policy topic it's a moral issue climate
is a question that bears directly on the
fate of your mortal Soul when you
mistreat the climate you risk damnation
in so much as you have done to the least
of these you have done it to the climate
big change you thought it was about the
science actually it's about morality
okay Reverend Pete so you set the terms
here
so how's your climate record that seems
like a fair question given that you've
just told us that we will go to hell for
our carbon emissions so let's see how
you're doing
Fox News digital just got a hold of the
Reverend Pete's travel schedule a list
of trips he's taken since getting the
job at the transportation department and
it turns out that Reverend Pete is the
Jimmy Swaggart of climate clergy he was
commanding you not to do it the same
time he was doing it himself in a very
big way way more than you've ever
thought of doing it Reverend Pete has
sinned oh boy has he in a dark and very
naughty way
in less than two years but a judge has
flown private at taxpayer expense nearly
20 times he's jetted to Ohio in Florida
New Hampshire among other places in
September Buddha judge took an FAA jet
to a Canadian gay rights ceremony to
accept an award for his lgbtq plus
advocacy something else he's been doing
since he gave up on the roads
all this has been extremely expensive
for you and every other taxpayer you may
recall that Donald Trump's HHS secretary
Tom Price lost his job for doing exactly
the same thing an outraged politico.com
drove him out of office
so it's expensive
but that's not the real crime the real
crime here is against the climate it's a
sin it's a moral transgression because
none of these planes the Buddha judge
was jetting around on were solar powered
not a single one ran on a windmill a
recycled french fry oil they were all
fossil fueled all of them
and there is likely no mode of
transportation in the history of
machines that emits more carbon than
private air travel that include long
trips across India on coal-fired
locomotives private jet travel stands
alone private jets emit an average of
two tons of carbon dioxide in an hour
per hour
for perspective that's 14 times more
carbon emissions per passenger than the
JetBlue flight euron or any other
commercial flight
so you might as well start a tire fire
to heat your house that would be better
for the atmosphere than what people the
judge is doing traveling by private jet
is literally the last thing that father
Pete should ever do
but we shouldn't be surprised that he's
doing it
you may remember that last year when
people the judge was busted commuting in
a carbon belching SUV one of the
vehicles that destroys the climate then
eluding a bicycle from the back seat for
a short widely photographed ride to the
White House you're seeing that footage
on your screen now
now that should have been the very first
tip that Reverend Pete's Sherman's in
the self-described climate activists who
applauded those sermons are all entirely
fraudulent
and in fact they are fraudulent
roughly half of all emission created by
airplanes are emitted by the richest one
percent of the population flying private
the right majority of these Biden voters
and big fans of you guessed it the
Reverend people to judge
this year alone to pick up one among
many examples Steven Spielberg who said
he's terrified of climate change emitted
over 4 400 metric tons of carbon from
private jets how much is that that's 600
times more emissions than the average
person emits in a year
another climate activist Taylor Swift
nearly doubled Steven Spielberg's total
8 000 metric tons of CO2 in a year all
of them destroying the planet Rising the
Seas on a fence against mother earth now
Taylor Swift Justified it by saying oh I
loan out Jets sometimes oh it's okay
but it's not okay not if you claim to
believe in climate change a 50-minute
flight on a private jet can emit as much
carbon as the average person's car does
over an entire year
50 minutes
so imagine what a flight from DC to LAX
does or more likely from Hamptons to
Aspen and then imagine thousands and
thousands tens of thousands of these
flights all caring people who claim they
believe that climate change is quote
existential
it's not a mistake it's intentional it's
a statement and it's quite a statement
if you think about it if you're yapping
about carbon emissions and climate and
then flying private what you're really
doing is hoisting a screaming middle
finger to the country to the plebes
below in their SUVs which you say you
plan to ban
and not just in this country we've got
it easy the economies of entire nations
around the world are being destroyed
right now in the name of fighting
climate change at the behest of people
who fly private
so people are going hungry and freezing
to death around the world so that people
put a judge and his friends won't have
to walk through the magnetometer at the
TSA checkpoint
I'm going to mean to singer out the
Reverend Pete though he is
certainly the most self-righteous of the
group
they're all doing it is there a single
high-level climate activist who doesn't
fly private
at the recent climate Summit more than
400 attendees flew in privately not on
JetBlue in their own planes Jeff Bezos
is one of them he flew in his private
jet so to Boris Johnson John Kerry was
famously busted flying to a climate
Summit in Iceland on his personal Gulf
Stream
but don't worry he had no choice he's
too important watch
it's the only choice for somebody like
me who is traveling the world to win
this battle I believe the time it takes
me to get somewhere I can't sail across
the ocean I have to fly to meet with
people and get things done
oh someone like me you never heard of
Zoom pal you should be in jail by your
own standards you're a climate Criminal
you're a climate criminal you should be
imprisoned by your own standards
not just him virtually every
recognizable person in American politics
and entertainment flies private Nancy
Pelosi flies private Barack Obama flies
private Leonardo DiCaprio famous five's
probably you know who flies private a
lot Al Gore flies private
Michael Bloomberg boy does he fly
private in a four-year period the U.N
climate Envoy Mr Bloomberg
took more than 1700 private flights
burning more than 10 000 metric tons of
CO2 you could never do that
if you filled your yard with diesel
engines and never turned them off you
would not do that your car emits less
than five metric tons of CO2 a year
so this is Meaningful this is an actual
offense against Mother Earth and the
climate
so you have to wonder what the Defenders
of climate think of this what about the
climate Warriors at Greenpeace and the
Sierra Club and the environmental
defense fund if they notice that's not
really
have they scolded their donors for
undermining their core message
no of course not
Catherine Clark the incoming Democratic
Party House whip doesn't complain either
she should be because her own child has
nightmares about climate change
let me tell you what it means to to me
coming in as a different generation I
remember my middle child waking up with
nightmares over concern around climate
change
okay so you terrorized your own children
you scared the crap out of little kids
about climate
so you must be very upset about what
Pete Buddig does who's doing to climb it
by flying private
which is the most destructive thing you
can do to climate other than signing off
on the sabotage of a Russian natural gas
pipeline which I guess they also did but
who's noticing
but she's not worried about Catherine
Clark doesn't care another two are
donors including the environmental
activists who send her all that money
meanwhile a lot of young people are very
upset about climate they believe Pete
put a judge and you know what they're
doing they're destroying some of the
greatest artwork in western civilization
because they want you to know how
important the climate is
[Applause]
[Music]
during these times climate change is
needed now more than ever
what is worth more art or life we cannot
afford new oil and gas it is going to
take everything we know and love
so groups like that those thugs those
monsters the stalinist mobs didn't
appear out of nowhere it's not organic
of course they were whipped into a
frenzy by John Kerry and Nancy Pelosi
and Pete Buddha judge those were their
inspiration
but what's interesting is they're
destroying the things that value most
that are most valuable in our society
our art the legacy of our civilization
but you know what they haven't done
they even said a single word about Al
Gore's personal Gulf Stream or John
Kerry's or Pete Buddha judge
well that's weird isn't it they're
attacking our civilization's art but
they're not saying anything about the
people who are actually destroying the
climate and he knew else isn't BlackRock
the ESG score that you keep hearing
about
your flights on private planes have no
effect on an ESG score really the E is
for environment
but BlackRock doesn't say a word
could it be that the climate movement
isn't really about the climate or about
the environment could it be the climate
movement is really about creating a
permanent caste system where the people
at the top of society the brahmanas can
do literally whatever they want
can violate with impunity the standards
they impose on others will endlessly
lecturing and oppressing the population
that supposedly runs the country but of
course actually doesn't
could it be oh it's possible we call
people to Judge's office today and asked
how you can justify flying private as
the Earth warms and the Seas rise how
are you not a climate criminal speak
slowly so we can understand
of course they didn't explain
but the rest of us should impose this as
a litmus test going forward no one who
seeks to impose carbon rationing on
another human being should ever be
allowed to step within a hundred yards
of a private aircraft period anyone who
claims to be serious about fighting
climate change should demand tomorrow
morning a federal law against private
air travel
make it illegal it's that simple then go
ahead and fly commercial with everyone
else or stay home
what's the argument against that
well here's what you do know anyone who
lectures you about climate and opposes
Banning private air travel is a total
fraud and should be ignored subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight